we're very excited to have toxic ricin
here with us
is an associate research professor and
assistant director of scholarship
programs in the department of family
medicine there he serves on several
awards including the Journal of
Excellence in college teaching the
international journal to the scholarship
of teaching and learning
higher ed of teaching and learning
portal Tec enriched instruction which is
a Microsoft program and the
communicating science and k12 or
currently he's working on faculty
development effective instructional
strategies and student learning areas
research he's co-authored two books on
mentioned here teaching for learning and
the new science of learning was received
the National Award for innovation
thanks for so so I'm getting more and
more confused these days so one of the
things I find when you teach psychology
so I started out as research as I was
actually I didn't start out as a
research anything I guess I was
collecting data at a very young age I
started out in my academic career here
in Southern Oregon University and I was
a system professor got promoted
associate professor got tenure had fun
with that then I rescinded tenure and
went to Central Michigan and started
playing around with faculty development
stuff I built a center there did that
after seven years got chance to go down
to University in North Carolina and then
moved over to the medical school when
you teach psychology something cool kind
of happens in your intro psych class you
tell everybody all the neat stuff that
happens in psychology and then about the
second year so you start teaching I
taught statistics and then methods and
then like cognitive psych and when I got
to cognitive psych I started telling
people well there's a lot of stuff we
don't know but we do know some things
and then I taught history and systems
capstone course and capstone course I'd
be teaching well actually we don't know
much of anything but there's certain
areas we're really making some progress
then I went off to graduate school and I
spent probably the next four years
looking at cognitive aspects of parfaits
performance appraisals trying to figure
out if maybe I could shed a little tiny
bit of light on how you actually
evaluate an employee's performance when
you might only evaluate them once every
six months but you see the performance
every day what actually plays into that
and the point I'm making here is I
started with this concept of here's what
we know and got all the way to here's a
tiny Larry I can make a contribution
teaching and learnings the same thing I
started out feeling like okay here's
some great stuff about teaching and
learning and here's some stuff that we
all know and I'm getting slowly to that
spot we're kind of wondering what we
actually do know for sure but there are
some things we know for sure and there's
some things that we know don't work very
well so we're gonna play around with
that area just a little bit so I've got
like five major points and I've numbered
them because if I number them you're
more likely to remember them if I don't
number them so here we go this is a
great quote that our statement that I
have learning is best what it involves
the learner okay this is ridiculous
right concept here is that if we don't
involve the learner if the person's not
involved in the process learning is
actually very difficult but there's a
concept we get into in just a minute in
terms of how people learn now we've been
teaching and learning for a long time
here's actually something from about 900
years ago the concept if you think about
it for a second is what happens if there
are no books just for a moment no books
no internet there are certain
individuals who know things and other
people do not know things if you're
someone who wants to know something you
have to go to the person who does know
things and that individual would have to
show you
oops that individual have to show you
what it is that's going on or tell you
and that would be here of course came
out of church traditions here and then
these individuals would want to write it
down so you don't forget and what's cool
is lectures from like 900 years ago have
some interesting phenomenon if you look
up here and you'll see this see this is
those are the excited people those are
all in the front row those are the
students that are going to sit up front
and write down every word you say
and in back here you have people with
side conversations and then you've got a
dude here who's sleeping
you got the TAS down here and then this
is so weird
one person texting now the difference is
nowadays we have many more people
texting than we used to but the idea
here is that little by little you know
this is kind of what came out of it now
if you think about for just a minute
teaching is the profession that makes
all professions possible that's Todd
Whitaker I like that quote teaching is
the profession that makes all
professions possible if you think about
how far we advanced from here just a
commercial travel for example for
commercial travel and what we are able
to do now versus just thirty years ago
40 years ago was amazing televisions
televisions 50 years ago were these tiny
little black-and-white TVs you remember
what used to happen at midnight anybody
here old enough yeah midnight this they
would play the national anthem and then
it would go down to a test pattern and
then it would either go down to a dot or
just go to snow and or everybody in here
is my age or roughly my age we used to
just stare at the TV until 6 o'clock in
the morning until it would come back no
actually what we used to do is sleep it
was weird
so now it's different but the point is
you had these little televisions now we
have Jumbotrons that are the size of
buildings
so how has education changed massively
we have bigger rooms
all right that's kind of mean concept is
if we think about how far the field of
education has helped other people to go
we should be making some massive changes
which we are making some but the concept
here is we should be moving a little
quicker so today I want to play around
with a couple of concepts so here's the
first one think about an average first
year course you come in the student
comes in sits down starts to start take
home notes and stuff the teacher starts
to lecture how long before the students
are going to get bored so what kind of
time spans would you put on this how
long before a student gets bored when
you start to lecture twenty minutes is
good how much 15 that's even better 10
nicely done
I had a sense of where this is going
alright any other numbers one of the
numbers you got five is good we're the
true pessimists in the crowd there's a
one well done the best number I ever
heard probably for an actual number was
minus thirty seconds and that's when and
when a student's walking into the room
thinking ho man it's gonna be a lecture
I'm already bored so that we get
anywhere from now zero up to 20 minutes
right so those are all over the place
but try another one so we have some
issues there with lecturing so we could
work at that for just a second here's
another one person picks up a book I am
NOT gonna argue about whether or not
people read I see books around all the
time people will read so just for a
second if you do come in and sit down
for a lecture that's listening to the
lecture if you pick up a book and start
to read how long before a person gets
bored while reading weight depends on
what okay depends on what you're reading
what else would it depend on your
motivation your mood I got at least I
got to get to at least seven here it's
blood sugar yes the blood sugar your
ability to actually pay attention to it
that's a good one now we're up to four
we can get to seven yes yeah looking at
the book thinking wow this thing goes on
forever so that's a good one time of day
is a good one the purpose behind reading
what's the interest of this thing too so
we got that we did it we got to seven so
the interest the purpose the blood sugar
levels all those things you know what I
find intriguing I have done this now on
my own campus about five or six
different groups and I've done it around
the country for about another eight or
nine groups just did this a few times
total maybe fifteen times every time has
had the same result how long before a
person gets bored during lecture I get
time estimates every single time I said
what about reading and the very first
responses it depends why does it depend
for reading and not for a lecture and
what if you think back about those
things that you just said it depends on
for a lecture what if we took your list
from the book and transposed it on to
the lecture blood sugar
time of day interest the thickness of it
whether it's presenter whether the
information is is legible as is
accessible or not accessible could be
another one whether you're required to
sit there versus not required to sit
there
you read it versus you're required to
read it the fundamental thing I'm after
on this one and we do know this but I'm
not hearing people talk about it and I'd
love to have them do it more is the
difference between the reading and the
lecturing they're fundamentally one-way
pieces of communication that which a lot
of people would call passive learning
you know we think about them
fundamentally differently think about a
bad movie if you walk out of a bad movie
how many times do you walk and I have a
terrible time walking out of a movie
once I'm in there I got to see it
through to the end usually I meet my
wife down the street at a coffee shop an
hour later she has no problem walking
out I've never seen people walk out of a
movie though saying wow that movie was
quite complex and I'm not sure I had the
cognitive capacity to really truly
understand that which the director was
going for no usually we say that was a
terrible movie so we put it on the movie
very quickly so I just want to be
careful because the books we talked a
lot about the reader characteristics and
very quickly for the lecture we go right
to the students getting bored and so
that's where we got to be a little bit
careful so here's another one that this
came from actually I shouldn't say
another one where this whole discussion
came from is a couple months ago someone
in the medical school at UNC was writing
an article about active engaged learning
and lecturing and said I've gotten to
the portion of the article where I've
written that after X amount of time we
have to change things up because
students get bored okay she said could
you please find me a good article so I
can plug in the amount of time I've put
ten minutes in there as a placeholder
could you find me a study that I can
cite in the amount of time that should
be put in there the next thing was what
I normally do people call me a lot were
these things on my campus and I say sure
no problem I can get to you tonight then
I went and searched the literature I
checked the medical literature
I checked the psych little most of my
stuff
I looked all through the literature you
want know what I found I found hundreds
of articles talking about students
getting bored in the classroom I can't
find anybody who's collected data
there's some mind-wandering stuff out
there that's close there's some
self-report stuff out there that was
really weakly done but quite frankly and
I don't mean like
every week it was weekly done but
there's also some stuff out there from
the 1980s on heart rates basically
demonstrated that when students come
into the classroom their heart rates are
up here then through the first 20
minutes their heart rates go down like
this well that's obviously boredom or
people running to class with backpacks
in fact sometimes when my heart rate is
down very low I'm still not bored at all
like a frosty beverage at Adirondack
chair and an ocean you know I can be
fairly relaxed and still engage thinking
deep thoughts
so the point there is I can't find the
data if you think about it for just a
second you researchers in here think
about this how would you even
operationally define these variables we
I think this can be done I'm just
waiting for somebody to do it so the
point is without self-report using
something other than heart rate which is
a pretty nebulous measure here we'd have
to just define what do we mean by
boredom Oh we'd have to control for the
lecture we'd have to control for the
content we'd have to control for
interest level we'd have to control for
complexity
we'd have to control for length the
point here is we have to be really
careful before we make a global
statement like every 10 minutes we have
to change things up because people get
bored at least till we find some data on
that now we do know that mind attention
can go down even without specific data
we know it can but instead of framing
this is because people get bored let's
do engagement what if we reframed it -
there's a certain point at which the
cognitive load is high enough and you've
gone through enough material that you
need some application or to do something
with that as opposed to just getting
more stuff there comes a point as hard
as you want to pay attention that if you
cognitively if you're full up you're
just going to be done and by the way
novices get really full a whole lot
faster than experts do when you're
talking about new information so just
that concept of thinking it through ok
so here's your your final exam on this
slide how long can it if you're doing a
flipped classroom how long can a video
be before the average watcher is going
to be bored yay
is good I got a copy of my book I'm
gonna give you sorry who said the seven
minutes that's yours
you knew better oh wait a minute that
was mean all right was that borderline
mean oh all right well go over to the
center and they'll give you a copy
I had three copies when I came here what
happened to the other one I'll figure it
out
Hey remind me I got you a Bloom's
taxonomy slider it's right over there
you can have one of those help let's do
that
now I feel bad gosh it's my snippy
little attitude gets me in trouble could
you pass this back thank you all right
it's actually it's better than the book
okay now yeah it depends but when people
are flipping classrooms over and over
again I'll hear folks say make sure your
videos not more than three minutes
because students won't watch it yeah
they will if it's good and if it's bad
you I know how I think for a second of
how quickly you become bored watching a
video that's a bad video I can usually
make it about 3 to 5 seconds and then
I'm done so if you're gonna sit behind a
desk and read to the monitor the notes
then that's going to not work out so
again if we rethink this so we're not
talking about amount of time before
someone gets bored but rather what
information has to be present to not
make it boring and then what's the
absolute load we can do before a person
can't process it any more we have a
different conversation but I have so
many people out there talking about
shifting things up because of the
boredom let's stop using boredom as a
defining characteristic what I'm after
along that same line active versus
passive learning I mentioned before I'm
becoming more and more confused so
here's my confused one I cannot figure
out as a cognitive psychology who's been
dab the kind of psychologist dabbling in
this neuroscience stuff and by the way
brain based learning is stupid and I got
to say that only because I was a I was a
guest editor for a journal excellence in
college teaching a special issue on
brain based learning I've done some
workshops on brain based learning
I'm doing it because I'm paying
to those crowds out there I will admit
it because I keep thinking to myself
what's next after brain based learning
we have like spleen based learning was
sure we have some monosynaptic motor
reflexes that we have but I don't see
that as a whole line of inquiry the
concept here is that pretty much all
learning is brain based right pretty
much all there now here's one passive
learning what would be I'm just gonna
ask you for a second what the heck is
passive learning we got an idea what
this would be I'm saying all right the
IRB committee gets really angry if you
suggest that is a research design by the
way I put it try two things I'm gonna
put people into groups and I'm gonna
peel these heads off so basically the
person just sits there and informations
poured in that's what we call it right
that's typically what we call it so what
are some examples of passive forms of
learning what kind of pedagogical
process would you be engaged in you guys
know what lecture is definitely one so
what's another one that's similar to a
lecture reading all right reading could
be it what videos watching a movie that
would be a that'd be kind of passive
it's basically sitting back and letting
the information come one way into your
being right I'm just saying this because
that is very very common verbiage I hear
all over the place active engaged
learning goes together you're doing
stuff we're broken into small groups
we're really messing with this thing
service-learning team based learning
problem-based learning
poggle stuff flipped classrooms we got
all this stuff going on that's all
active passive I'm sitting back and
letting stuff just come flooding into me
I think that's a terrible dichotomy and
I would love it if you could just help
me out I've just started this recently
just pushing this out to just get
completely rid of this because I'm
thoroughly convinced in fact there's
some good evidence on this that sitting
back and having information poured into
our head or watching a lecture or
watching a movie or reading a book can
be very very active and very very
effective as I said that statement I
actually have to notice the hesitation
in there because the whole concept of
just even saying out loud you know
reading a book can be informative that
kind of would mess with us if we if we
somehow ran a study and said you know
what's weird is small group work does a
really good job at long-term retention
but reading a book seems like it's a
waste of time that would change our
whole educational landscape so here's
the issue we get into passive versus
active what we're really talking about
here is the extent to which the learner
is involved in the learning process
first of all all learning has to be
active because neurons have to fire in
order for the learning to happen and
then learning happens the question is is
it transient is it going to hang around
for very long you know if you cram the
night before the test you go in the next
day it's all gone that's not passive
learning that's transient learning it's
comes in and it's gone so the question
we have now is what helps it to stick
around for a while so here's an
interesting concept
suppose a suppose an individual watched
a movie and then got really nervous
going in swimming in the ocean now if a
person actually could change all of
their behavior and the whole life view
and change what they like to do simply
because they watched a movie that made
them afraid to swim in the ocean
right then it'd be bizarre because it's
a very passive situation I'm sitting
back I'm having this information come to
me and yet behavior changes in fact just
watching that movie can change it if you
are now anybody in the room thinking of
the title of a movie right now alright
which is weird because that movie
happened a long time ago if you've ever
listened to a lecture I listened to a
lecture I was talking about earlier
today I've listened to lectures that in
a matter of seconds changed my entire
worldview I never got into a group I
never stood up I never did anything but
sit there and say oh my gosh that's
amazing
now before we go too far and I make the
Center for Teaching learning folks
really ain't angsty here you should
never do active learning you should
always lecture all the time no that's
not the argument here the point is let's
not dismiss lecturing completely let's
not dismiss this passive learning
concept completely and it changed
instead change the framework a little
bit so what is it whether we're pouring
information in and the pouring
information is actually a really good
way to describe it because in some
respects that brings
the image that the learner isn't really
seeking the information out it just
happens to be there but the concept is
whether I'm going to try to cross a
boundary here that doesn't get crossed
very often I'm gonna say it doesn't
matter if it's active learning engage
learning team-based learning any kind of
think pair shares jigsaw a lecture a
movie anything you're exposed to let's
go for for this time for things that
have to be present if you're gonna
remember that which you're exposed to a
couple of months later or a couple of
weeks later say anything passed like a
couple of days so what has to be present
if you're gonna have this later yeah
tensions number one if you don't attend
to it you can't learn it if I'm walking
along and the person in front of me
trips and falls over something and I
think wow I'm gonna step aside ooh
here's one for you one of my students
said he was walking in New York City and
apparently they didn't latch one of
those grates where they deliver the
packages and so he was walking along and
the grate flipped and he slid down the
delivery chute into the basement of this
place the owner comes busting through
the door and says what are you doing in
here get out he's you know I didn't want
to be here and so they went through that
whole process the rest of his life he
will not step on one of those grates
that was very active learning he was
very engaged in the process the person
behind him though walking along and said
whoa at dudes in trouble that's I'm not
involved directly in it but I've seen it
right so if I attend to it that changes
how I might step on grates but imagine
for a second I was walking and the
person fell in the grate behind me and
if I kept walking I'm the same distance
from the person but because I never
attended to the stimulus that's being
presented I never learned anything so
you have to attend I promise not to go
that long on the rest of them but you
have to have attention now what else
would you need yes
practice practice is a good one if you
practice and do something with it
we know that if we practice it retrieval
we actually strengthen the pathways to
get back to the information so we have
practice so we have some prior knowledge
prior knowledge is huge very good to is
so if we don't have some relevant prior
knowledge which has huge implications
for individuals who are learning from
less impoverished or more empowered
environments than other people so that
individual becomes different that
becomes a difficult situation so the
relevant knowledge so you can hook it
because now what we're actually talking
about the lab eration if you can take
information and hook it to stuff you
have from before if you can practice at
the retrieval and if you attend to it
huge characteristics and then one more
there we go we'll go with interest you
ever noticed the big difference that you
all feel when you're actually listening
to something you're very interested in
versus listening to something that's
boring listen to next time that you're
really bored at a story somebody's
telling by the way there's a whole
nother component that is kind of a fun
side note we oftentimes don't even
process what we're processing like
you'll become bored and all of a sudden
is like wow I'm bored next time you say
wow I am bored think about why you're
bored for a second it's really kind of
an interesting concept this is what I do
when I'm bored so I get less bored I get
bored watching a lecture and I'm
thinking wow I'm bored what is it that
did this oh you know what there's enough
redundancy here that that repetitive
information lost its value hmm
repetitive information lost the value
number to its I don't even care right
now I don't care and when I go through
and list those types of things out I can
figure out what it is that's happening
but if you have the four things you
mentioned it changes how we process it
so instead of talking about active
versus passive learning we could talk
about the extent to which learning
scenarios have things like those
characteristics now they're out there
we've talked about them for years but we
don't usually put them in the category
and move away from this dichotomy into
the other dichotomy of to what extent
should these things be there so I think
there's a huge potential there well
there we just did that one or way ahead
we have lots of stuff happening right
now and there are lots of different ways
of engaging the learner and things even
starting at a very young age this is
actually an old poll go thing so that's
the process inquiry case based learning
we have as the way humans are structured
a huge affinity to for storytelling we
can weave stories together so well so in
some areas when you learn in some areas
stories work incredibly well there's
other areas you know organic chemistry
it's harder to tell some of the stories
you know into if you have to learn
formulas in
formulas it's hard people actually will
try to make up stories about formulas
through mnemonic devices mnemonic
devices that's funny you pump them up
and they're really good that's a
mnemonic devices so there you go so
through the his demonic devices stuff we
try to tell stories the point is
storytelling is incredibly effective but
it doesn't always work learning is
changing completely and what it looks
like somebody can be sitting in a
classroom sitting in a classroom while
they're sitting anywhere so these things
happen but the thing I really wanted to
point out I don't really want to yeah
is this this is from Dee Fink's can
creating significant learning
experiences as we're putting these
things together through storytelling
prior knowledge and looking at a lot of
the characteristics what de Fink has
found is it's not just this foundational
knowledge when we teach it's not just
about the foundational knowledge it's
it's really looking at how we process
information from a lot of perspectives
for instance if you want people to know
something like not to know me
teach the knowledge if you want them to
apply something to teach application we
know right now that if you just teach
the knowledge component and then later
say now apply it some people can but
it's difficult to apply until you see
how to apply it
here's a quick side note just a quick so
I taught statistics for so many years I
love statistics you know it's an
inherently interesting field right so we
like this anybody who doesn't
particularly care for statistics should
not teach it they should teach something
boring like econ so now if you think
about the statistics and the first day
of class I used to say to my students
all right think about how think about as
many ways as you can that a person who
collects numbers for a living has
impacted your life just any kind of
numbers any kind of data has affected
your life a couple quick examples what
would it be how people impacted your
life yes graduate school okay what
numbers where they have collected
all right good all right go for it I
like yeah yeah okay so I'm just agreeing
with you I think that what you said was
fabulous I don't got a clue what it is
you said it with authority with
conviction and so I believe you all
right other ways yes oh how would that
work oh you got to write tickets for
collecting numbers for that okay so one
more all right let's just pause for just
one more go ahead doctors I work with
evening physicians or doctors see they
ask me am i because I work in a hospital
they say are you a real doctor and I say
yes I am NOT a physician that is not
funny
I'm just kidding around I didn't I
forget about the videotape sometimes so
yes for doctors collecting all kinds of
information about very important things
where they save lives on a daily basis
this is gonna get me in trouble but I
got to go on this tiny little sidetrack
here to is if anybody ever says you know
what you do is important but I like save
lives your response should be yeah me
too because they'll say if they make a
mistake a person could die if you make a
mistake a person could die they would
because if you think about it if a
person is really dreaming about doing
something really in their heart has
something you want to do and we teach in
such a way that makes it impossible for
them to learn and by the way there's
ways of doing that and we make it almost
impossible for them to learn and
therefore they don't do that thing you
find them years later this shell of a
person doing some tasks doesn't have to
be a menial task it could be anything
even important but it's not what they
wanted and so that day they died a
little on the inside and then the rest
of their life they're just a zombie-like
worker it's sad we killed them so we got
to teach well so the pressure is there
so here we go
the statistics thing a little dramatic
but it's okay so if you're looking at
the chairs all of the chairs you're
sitting in on the same chairs although
we have different human beings in them
somebody had to determine how high that
chair should be somebody had to figure
out how high the table should be how
bright the lights should
how wide the door should be how many
lumens this light should be up here
people have collected data on how wide
roads should be how hard it should be to
turn a steering wheel to make a car
change how far should you turn the wheel
or the ignition before that comes on
while I'm on the car it's how hard you'd
push for the brakes to come in on
flights they had to figure out how big
the seats are and then reduce them by
20% they had all of this stuff that
people did and they do that because of
course they can put more seats in they
have now figured out on some airlines
how to change the seat configuration so
they can make the toilet smaller yeah
even smaller than it was and put like
two more seats in the plane because that
can generate X amount of revenue
everything you do has data attached to
it I would say that to my students and
I'd say now write all the things you can
think about and they would write long
lists really fast just a few seconds
before they were struggling to come up
with two or three things if we want them
to know application we have to teach
application if we want to know
integration we teach integration and
then the whole left side of this thing
is all about the human beings I always
tell people and I think it's very
important we've got good evidence on
this one too at the very least a student
should think you care about them that's
the very least we should care but they
should at least think we care the point
is that down the left hand side this
human dimensions we learn different ways
and caring is important and teaching
people how to learn boy another one that
I got the big soapbox on right now we
have really really bright students going
into universities who teaches people how
to learn and could you imagine if we
take the really bright people at a
younger age and teach people how to how
to work the process of learning how to
know when you're learning well what's
happening what works well what doesn't
work well if we taught people that the
amount that they could achieve would be
significantly more than it currently is
which is based a lot of implicit
assumptions in trial and error
listening to music good solid research
on this one by the way do you know under
what situation listening to music is
actually beneficial number one lot I
won't even ask you to raise your hands a
lot of people love to listen to music
cuz I must my daughter does this I have
to listen to music or I can't study
periodically I'll go in the room and the
music's not playing and I'll say hey
there's no music should go wow that's
weird
click and star
playing again I'll say what he been
doing she said studying I said that's
not physically possible cuz you told me
you can't study without the music she
said yeah I was just really engrossed in
this and I couldn't remember I didn't
notice it wasn't playing I said well
then that's weird so you can study
without the music she's no I can't so
there's this really strong implicit
assumption there when can you listen
what under what circumstances would
listening to music actually help there
is one now this is wild learning if
you're studying though if you're
actually studying something I'm going to
book let's do book learning I'm reading
a book and when times with music help
you distract you from the book oh that's
good yes if it's basically if it's
basically melodic white noise if what
you're doing is having a noise that is
in your immediate environment that you
can tune out but drowns out the noise
which might draw your attention then it
can be helpful some people which you
didn't do good for you will say like
instrumental music it's not the fact of
this instrumental music it's not
meaningful music it's something you
won't listen to if you're reading along
did it don't you reading about yeah I
don't know so this is the problem we run
into if there's actually music to study
by on the internet and I'm thoroughly
convinced the Internet's going to take
off so you should check it out
but the concept there is its melodic
noise and melodic noise melodic white
noise that's out there so that helps but
learning how to learn huge impact so
learning how to learn the carrying human
dimensions we have all of these
characteristics in here now when we
bring those into things like group work
how many of you seen Hakes study stuff
before I mean and how many of not raise
your hand how many of just morally
opposed to raising your hands oh that's
good none of you that's really good so
usually I was a couple I'm just going to
do this one really really quickly it's
basically what Haake did and this is
only for content he basically went in
physics class and he did a pretest he
did a post-test post-test minus the
pretest gives you your game each one of
these data points here's an entire class
so this is 6,000 students basically
normalized gains and here's what they
found if if for
instance your pretest was 84 the whole
group the post-test was a hundred that'd
be a 20-point gain this line right here
is the maximum the GMAX here that's the
maximum amount you could get which would
be because of the hundred percent final
test you don't want a hundred percent on
the final anyway it's a ceiling effect
so we don't care that no one's on this
line but the higher is more learning for
these concepts now for the other stuff
that happens just a concept test which
has its own issues but it's a concept
test the point here is he did this for
high school college and university did
it for interactive engagement which
means you stop lecturing periodically
and you do active engagement kinds of
things a traditional lecture a
traditional lecture there's great meta
analyses about traditional lectures too
you come in high lecture if you have any
questions come see me in my office hour
and I walk out that's a traditional
lecture what he found 6,000 students
high school college university all of
the lectures were down here amongst the
worst of the interactive classrooms so
what I think that the team wanted me to
share with you from the center from
teaching and learning and all the stem
stuff is that you should stop lecturing
and do crappy group work and you'll
break even all right that's not the
message of the day okay hold on
the concept here is it's really hard if
all a person does is lecture to keep up
with this interactive engagement now
here's what's really important and I
have to admit I made a mistake on this
when I first started talking about this
stuff that Craig Nelson who's at Indiana
University doing all kinds of critical
thinking stuff he was one who said you
see you can't keep up the worst of the
lectures can barely keep up with the
best I'm sorry the best of the lecturers
with the worst of the interactive there
was no indication here of a hundred
percent engagement the interactive
engagement is a mixture of lectures and
engagement this is only lecture think
about it for just a moment as if this
was something like what if this is
exercise and this is diet and exercise
the concept here is that the interactive
engagement was added to the lecture
there is still some lecture there if we
saw a
cuddy like this and said you know
exercise will do this but diet and
exercise would do this we wouldn't then
come back and say oh good if this was
for exercise and this is daya for
exercise we should stop exercising see
that would not make sense but there's
been a whole generation of faculty
members because this is around 20 years
old who have used this and said hey we
should stop lecturing Caryl Wyman has
the same thing now just say quickly he
did a lecture versus active learning but
the active learning was engagement with
these things and what I want to just
point out is over and over again the
people who do all traditional lecturing
a hundred percent of the time cannot
keep up with the individuals who bring
in activities it just doesn't happen
over over again but none of this says to
stop lecturing altogether so those of
you who do lecture and like lecture I do
think it knows it does not need to be
vilified I think there's some good
components to it it's just we shouldn't
be doing it all the time I wanted to
throw this up as a background slide just
to say group work and active learning is
good and it's helpful but once I got the
slide and started looking at it it
suddenly occurred to me this actually
explains exactly why group work should
be done do you see it
it makes your students beautiful these
are the best-lookin students in a group
I've ever seen so if you want your
students to be as beautiful as these
students you should use group work you
notice what else it is about them
they're beautiful and what happy look
how happy they are what do you say over
here I said well there's some diversity
I've gotten in trouble from this
statement before and it is being
videotaped but I will just say and I try
to do this in this kind of way as
possible it's about a diversity that
shows some diversity but doesn't scare
people if you look at shots that are
staged they will stage him in such a way
that there's just the right amount of
diversity which drives me absolutely
crazy because it's fake stuff but yeah
they got just a little bit of it I got
males and females oh yeah but here's the
point act in fact I don't even know what
she's looking at
but she's happy and here's the issue we
do have and I got to move on but I'm
just going to say this so that was the
big joke as it makes him beautiful
here's the thing I think a lot of
faculty when they're using group work
think this but the problem is that if we
think this is what group work will look
like it's not what you tend to see and
what we tend to see from again study
after study after study is students I
mean it's not a hard call here students
don't typically like group work we
typically like to do group work I'm
telling you right now anytime I see
something that ubiquitously is done and
ubiquitously disliked I think there's
right for study there lots of study
there so I just and and what we find by
the way and I just want to move on
because we only have a few minutes left
is if we actually teach students how to
work well in groups we have seen us in
study after study teach students how to
work well in groups they do not hate
groups the students who typically
dislike the groups who are ones that are
told if my head if you think of me as a
character which isn't that hard and this
is like inside my head and I'm thinking
oh history and systems of psychology I
know I'm going to put my students I'm
gonna having working groups of six
they'll come up with an important
historical figure they'll each take a
piece of that historical figure and then
they'll do a group project I'm gonna do
a group grade oh this will be great okay
everybody get into groups of six I'm
thinking this is what's going to happen
if I haven't taught you how to work well
in groups that idea that someday you're
gonna have to work in groups so you
might as well learn it now how about
learning it now instead of just being
thrown into it could teach your kids how
to swim by saying there's the deep end
of the pool go but again not the ideal
way to teach them by the way this is
what we are after and this is more
likely what the students are thinking
that happens a lot and I have a daughter
who's now a she's at UNC and she's she
comes up with my best material for me
and she said hey daddy if you're going
to show them this one make sure you show
them this because they'll love this this
is the same kid that when she went off
to school on her first day of at UNC and
I wasn't UNC it was some other place
paying I hate videotapes what she went
off to school and she said I said how
was your first day of school and she
said now you know I was a Scylla Buster
gray when she comes up with the coolest
stuff a Scylla buster is when you just
basically talk so much the students
can't participate you just run through
the syllabus fill up the whole class
period then walk out that's a Scylla
buster she did tell me if I ever tell
anybody about the Scylla Buster that I
should also point out that it is her
favorite
first day so she wants you to do that I
don't she does but that's the point okay
so the concept here is if students are
disliking these things and by the way if
we teach them teach them some specific
components we know on day one and again
it doesn't take a doesn't take a rocket
surgeon to do this basically on day one
we know and we assign groups some of the
people in the group are going to want to
start on it that day other people are
going to want to wait until the day
before it's due we know sometimes they
are not sometimes we know in every group
there's going to be someone who's gonna
step up and try to take charge of the
group sometimes they don't usually they
don't there's gonna be one free writer
there's gonna be somebody in the group
who tries to do stuff and can't deliver
and somebody else in the group's got to
cover for them there's gonna be somebody
who gets sick and they get the flu and
everybody else is angry because that
person did wait till the last minute now
they got the flu they can't get the work
done somebody else has got to do it they
didn't really want to do the work and
then there's a group grade that's not
fair so we have all this stuff going on
we can teach them that out of the gate
and if you don't know how to do it you
go to your local Center for teaching and
learning and they have plenty of
resources and available research and
stuff for you all right so we can work
on that stuff
this is unfortunate because I got 12
minutes left and I'm down 2.2 oh they'll
go faster that's the little book that I
gave away but here's the big thing
teaching individuals metacognitive
processes been shown over and over again
to help out and basically what we do on
this one is teach people the learning
process here's a funky little thing I've
done with statistics for the longest
time I have students write down at this
when they put their name on the test
write down what score do you think
you're gonna get on this test before you
take the first question what do you
think you're gonna get end of the test
what do you think you got put that along
with what they actually get you got
three scores that is very informative if
the person writes down ninety five
seventy and gets a seventy they walked
through the door with the wrong level of
anticipation they realize taking the
test that things didn't go well and they
actually were accurate based on the test
of where they're at okay person comes
through the door and writes 7095 and
gets a seventy that's a whole different
issue came through the door thinking
they're gonna get about a 70% took the
test and thought I nailed it cuts the
test back in thinks wow that's way worse
than I expected anytime a student says I
didn't think it'd be that bad has a poor
cognition in terms of the metacognitive
process on what actually happened during
the test I've had those poor students
who have gone in and written down 95 95
and score 260 they didn't know woman in
they didn't know going out so that
concept is once you think about it and
play with it and work with it over time
you should get better and better at that
studies show that people get better at
it trying to reflect on different ways
of studying here's one for you
highlighting I've spoken to many many
studies many many effects re student
groups if I ask student groups to what
extent is highlighting effective the
students will say it is not effective
how about rereading not effective what
do you do we highlight we reread I say
why do you do that it's like well that's
what you're supposed to do I said really
cuz you just said it's not effective
they're just they're confused on what to
do so if you can help teach them what
type
some things to do practice it recall
talking to somebody else teach back let
me go home and tell somebody what you
learned today write out what you learned
in your own words and then later read it
and rewrite it again in different words
take a quiz over the material make up
flashcards do you when you run through
flashcards if you get it right do you
put it off to the side or do you leave
it in the stack there's research on that
too so the point is there's lots of
stuff we know about studies strategies
and cognitive processing of this it's a
process of teaching the students these
things so if you get better at this
stuff tends to get better oh these are
just cats time well use classroom
assessment techniques there's several
ways out there if you just go to the
Internet's and you type in that's my
daughter warned me of that when you get
old you put the word thaw in front of
stuff and make it plural you know going
to the Walmarts now i'm saying going to
the internets because i joke around with
it too much so go to the internets type
in classroom assessment techniques if
you have to put in the name Angelo
there's all kinds of things because if
you help the students see whether or not
they're getting it if at the end of the
class I just say okay for one minute
write down what you learned today at the
end of the class write down one thing
that you found just a little bit
confusing at the end of class what is
one way you can apply this at the end of
a class if you were gonna make a
newspaper clipping out of this what
would your headline be just something
that makes a person say okay this
because what a student what a human
being can do is read a book sit in a
lecture sit in a movie anything like
that I'm talking about
lectures and books as well get to the
end and realize oh my goodness for the
entire time I was thinking about bacon
and then you realize nothing happened
cognitively but your eyes went across
the pages or you looked at the
instructor and nodded and wrote stuff
and the people will look down and say
look what I wrote that's weird I don't
remember any of this we can zone out and
keep going if we actually test ourselves
periodically check and see these things
we can see if we're actually processing
when you're reading you can do micro
checks a micro check is essentially as
you're reading you just stop
periodically and say okay am I still
focusing you don't have to literally say
am I still focusing on a scale of 1 to 5
I think it to know it's basically you
just pause and then you keep going that
changes a situation from just kind of
going through and actually shouldn't
have a videotape here I know a person
that's not my wife
she reads she reads at night and what
happens is she reads till she goes to
sleep and then the next day she looks
through the book to try to figure out
where it was she stopped paying
attention and then she starts reading
from there again which means there's a
chunk of the book where her eyes are
going and she's not paying attention you
know we don't have a lot of time to
waste for academic reading we should
know when we're reading if we're reading
well and by the way we also know very
well if you are well rested and reading
there's an optimal reading you can do I
tell my students all the time by the way
first day of classes read the first five
pages time exactly how long it takes you
go through the pay those pages and have
a rough estimate of how much it takes
you pert a page to read two minutes five
minutes whatever it takes calculus books
very different from novels so the
concept is just how longs it take you to
read this stuff because then when a
person says oh I got a test tomorrow I
got to read two chapters it's going to
take me about an hour you know what
you're talking about it's not about an
hour this should take somewhere between
60 and 70 minutes so that concept of
starting to read and realizing three
hours later you just got through it I
don't work too well if you stop
periodically and check you can catch it
right when it happens that's good enough
with that here's a task for you how many
have you seen this grid of pennies
before anybody here just a couple people
of course that's good good we like to
use these in the field all right here's
one quick one for you don't google a
penny don't I phone a penny don't ask
for help on this one it's totally by
yourself don't you don't pull a penny
out it's just look up here and find
which of these is the real US penny even
let me see if this is I'm nervous I'm
going to turn off all the lights I
better just leave it alone
oh my god now don't share any
information I was all by yourself
all by yourself totally by yourself
you're working from your memories
all right got to keep moving for sake of
time
all right here's cool deal I'm just
gonna call these off real quickly you
just got to land on one pretty quickly
now and be proud when I say do you think
it's a think it's B put your hand in the
area if you look around and say I wonder
what other people are say that is weak
go for it are you ready how about a a my
like a couple a is good for you that's
good B's C's DS a couple DS good YZ f G
a couple G's going H's nicely done no
okay well there's other HS eyes yeah
look at all the eyes that is great J's
very good no see how supportive I am by
the way Ches excellent owls m's x and
o's that's cool i think totally you got
seven or eight i think i missed one of
them terms of the code seven or eight
and you've looked at this thousands of
times the correct answer is none of the
above I asked you which one of these was
a real u.s. penny is none of them they
are representations of u.s. pennies guys
I know that's mean I did that a few
years ago and one person the audience so
just none of them and I said yes
actually one of them is right they said
no it's not a zit yes it is they said no
it's not we did that love it and finally
he said they're all representations so I
said please and what what discipline you
think would say such a thing very good
philosophy very good good and we all
know that philosophers are just
psychologists without data so um now
that's the video again it's gonna happen
hit it here's the deal and just for sake
of time here we've looked at these
pennies thousands and thousands of times
mere repetition doesn't get something in
a long-term memory we have to pull
meaning with it or else we just dismiss
it but here's what's even more important
oh by the way if I don't tell you the
right answer and none of you will listen
a is the right answer which there was a
whole lot of people who picked I and
it's not that you're bad people is just
that you're didn't pick the right one
it's like I tell my daughter it's not
your behavior I'm disappointed in it's
you
so who picked a by the way there was a
couple see look at this that is really
good so a couple get people that's great
so here's the deal there's a whole field
out there whole area that is so cool
with psychology in the way that we
process information one of the things we
do if your brain is working properly is
when you have enough information to
bring about a result you stop processing
because if you keep processing and
processing and processing it's a little
like being OCD you keep processing a lot
of stuff if everybody looked up here
right now and right at this spot and I
said what's on the back wall okay it's
almost difficult it's really difficult
to not look I suppose so what's on the
back wall here by the way you might know
for sure another room that's a good one
yeah let's go a divider two breaks into
another room what colors the wall he
might know the color of the wall it's
weird as yeah so all of a sudden you can
look if you really have to it's just I
can play a game in a big room and say
okay somebody will say a big portrait
and I'll say who's the portrait of and
before I know it somebody's telling me
this elaborate painting of something
that doesn't exist
you shouldn't memorize everything I
could ask you how many lights there are
in this room and if you said oh there's
42 we'd worry about you so when we walk
into the room we need to know where's
the front of the room what are we gonna
be sitting and everything else and then
we're done and then we stop processing
when somebody's telling you a story that
seems to be going on a long time and you
know the point of the story you stopped
processing when a teacher is lecturing
on a topic and the student thinks okay I
got it and then you bring up another
example because experts know details and
little pieces so when I'm saying when
you're doing classical conditioning and
looking at the literature and looking at
the research and looking at this stuff
you want to be very careful because
sometimes an inhibitory stimulus looks a
lot like a neutral stimulus that it's
just the results are the same but for
the inhibitory stimulus you're actually
masking something and the students are
saying okay you don't do anything and if
they feel like they got it then they're
done and then they can think about bacon
or whatever else they're thinking about
I'm sorry I'm so meat-centric they could
be thinking about a grilled portobello
mushroom so the concept here is we look
at this
it's copper it's this big we're done we
don't pay attention to detail in the
class be very careful students will look
at what you're teaching and think okay
here's the general thing I've got it
let's move on if you ask them I've given
you three I'm gonna give you three
examples and I want you to tell me that
why I picked these three examples what's
going on there
homework assignments instead of five
homework problems here's four homework
problems and then explain to me what I
was going for those types of things
caused people to look at the details and
figure it out otherwise the brain is
wired to not do it
think about same kind of thing of the
brain and how we work these things if I
were to stand behind a lectern think
about this for just a second our brain
is wired to discount constant stimuli it
does it because it's an adaptive
mechanism for us we want to focus our
attention on things that move things
that could impact us stuff that could
kill us parked cars aren't gonna hurt
you moving cars are which means you'll
step right between two parked cars and
look both ways to see if there's a
moving car and then go across the street
but you'll step between those two parked
cars and not even think about the fact
that there are two cars there unless one
of them is moving like backing out and
then you'll wait moving objects valuable
station objects not so valuable we
actually have something sensory
adaptation we actually start to discount
anything that's constant here's a
physiological mechanism to explain in
psychology a classically conditioned
response is a naturally occurring
phenomenon which an unconditioned
stimulus reads leads to some kind of an
outcome which we call an unconditioned
response if you take a neutral stimulus
and pair it with the unconditioned
stimulus that previously neutral
stimulus will come to elicit a response
called a conditioned response that would
be similar to but not identical to the
unconditioned response if we now take
the unconditioned stimulus and pair it
with a new stimulus and a neutral
stimulus if you will that new stimulus
will come to elicit a new response which
we will call CR - or a conditioned
response - it never actually has to be
paired with an unconditioned stimulus
which was kind of fascinating because it
means the original
stimulus is no longer present and yet
you're creating a response which is
similar to but not identical to that
actual physiological response that is
natural in our natural process sorry
about messing up that last sentence now
though which I almost yawned myself I am
so bored right now I can't stand it
but when we say it was boring that
lectures boring it's not that it's
boring it's the brains are actually
discounting the information to the point
of not being able to attend to it you
have to fight to attend to that it's not
because of disinterest it's the way
we're wired
we got dopamine all right we started
five minutes late I promise I will
finish within the next couple of minutes
I had to have some myths I got some
evidence stuff out there anybody ever
see this learning pyramid we know 5% of
what we hear 10% of what we read 20% of
what we see cool if you ever have a few
minutes go look up learning pyramid and
myths this is made up this is all just
made-up stuff it's pretty cool the
reason they caught that it was made up
by the way I taught methods for a long
time look at these numbers yeah see
you're all laughing I can tell I can
tell the scientists when I'm speaking to
a group of people are quantitatively
oriented because if you ever have
somebody if one of your students turns
in a study and observation or whatever
you're reading something if you see 90
75 50 30 20 10 5 yeah go look it up and
basically what happened is somebody was
reading this report from the National
teaching learning laboratories and said
these numbers look very similar went to
the original citation the citation
didn't have the numbers in it called the
author of the article the author of the
article says I never put those numbers
in there and called back here and said
wait what about those numbers and the
ntl says well the person who did this is
no longer working here but we do own the
copyright so if you ever use the pyramid
you must cite us so I'm citing them now
anything they get all the credit for
this all the credit it's not my work
it's theirs
learning styles nonetheless things here
there's a whole concept we have study
after study article after article has
talked about meshing teaching to a given
learning style we got our we'll use
vark because marks a good index visual
vark visual auditory kinesthetic visual
auditory kinesthetic the theory is I
teach visual I put visual things in from
a visual learners auditory things and
kinesthetic things in and students learn
better problem is there's no evidence
for that in fact it's really tricky to
find evidence that the learning styles
exist but take two considerations if you
will number one if it really were true
that the visual people had to have
visual stuff if I showed a really good
visual representation and gave you all
the quiz you folks should outscore you
folks because it's visual your auditory
and kinesthetic if I do a kinesthetic
task you folks should outscore the rest
of the room doesn't actually happen if I
do a really good visual task even though
you are a visual auditory and
kinesthetic everybody seems to learn the
good news is this multimodal
presentation is advantageous so teaching
stuff that's got visual auditory and
kinesthetic stuff is good so I'm not
telling you if you've been teaching two
different learning styles keep teaching
that way blend it all together just
don't teach it as if the students
specifically learn from a given style
that's most important and I'll show you
example of that right now and then we
will be done the other part is where did
you find if you are a visual learner
think for just a moment this is where we
process stuff or we don't process stuff
think about where you would have found
out that you're a visual learner see I
used to ask people whose visual learners
that's like a trap that's just mean so
here's the deal if you were a visual
learner where would you have found out
to see somebody else mythically where
would you have found out to you're a
visual learner would you find this out I
have students every day telling me oh
I'm a visual learner I'm a kinesthetic
learner almost all visual learners
though where do you get your visual
learning this or where do you find out
the diagnostic criteria for this Vark
has a question here you can go online
and take a question here and the
question here will be things like do you
prefer to do this or do you prefer to do
that it's a learning preferences
inventory but the other part of this and
I could ask my psychologist colleagues
at some point if you want to know about
some state or trait of some trait of an
individual a
three-self scored 20 item questionnaire
on the internet not an ideal place to go
you can't go take a bunch of items and
just say oh look at me I'm this the
other place that comes from as teachers
who come by and say wow you are very
good at drawing you know what that
you're a visual learner aren't you and
you say uh-huh
I mean you're eight years old why not so
it's like uh-huh and Laius later in life
someone says are you what kind of
learner are you oh I'm visual I don't
even remember why so the problem is
people will put themselves in categories
and this is where I'll land is this is
from the onion so I want to make sure to
have really good evidence nasal learners
demand an odor based curriculum see this
little girl she's a nasal learner
struggling with an odorless textbook so
sad the bottom quote that gets cut off
here but I've done this enough I've just
memorized this thing as I said my 15
year old daughter Chloe used to goof off
and get in trouble with her friends now
I realize all those D's and F's did not
represent any failure on my daughter's
part but rather the school's failure to
provide an appropriate nasal based
curriculum if I'm a visual learner and
you don't use visuals it's not my fault
it's your fault if I'm a certain type of
learner you don't teach to me then it's
your fault I'm not learning and so what
I have with students all the time we
says I'm dr. Z I'm a like a visual
learner and you don't use a lot of
visuals first thing is when they say
visual learner I say me too which gets
camaraderie we're all together we're
visual learners and I know we've talked
through a little bit about this but be
careful about that response so all right
I've done well because my entire life I
go five minutes over and everywhere I've
gone I was gonna leave like six minutes
for questions which means I'm right on
time being five minutes over but I
didn't leave question time which is
unfortunate however I can hang around
for a few minutes and answer questions
if they are here but I know some of you
have places to get to go so I should
stop
so hopefully going through and looking
at this summarizing the big pieces we
have to be careful about the dichotomy
of saying here's passive versus active
here's engaged versus lecturing we
should Chuck lecturing we should Chuck
passive we have to be very careful about
saying people get bored during lectures
because we don't know exactly what's
going on there but we do know we have to
mix some things up once in a while we
now
you only have to watch out for learning
styles because that's an issue that we
have to get into but the big thing is
just learning how to process information
and thinking about how we're doing
things has a huge impact on how people
process information and what they can do
but gotta mix those things up oh the
active learning part still has to be in
there and there so there's the green
book again 101 educationally designed
active there's a whole bunch of stuff on
the web don't you have to buy the book
but the concept is there's a lot of easy
things to do and I would still argue go
see the folks who do this for a living
they can just sit down and help walk it
through so easily but I would really
encourage folks to start small if you're
doing lots of lecturing maybe a little
think-pair-share bring in some smaller
things down the road you can completely
change your class all up and everything
else but you know start small but bring
something into it but I'm gonna stop
there so let's stop right can you stop